這是第十集,題目是解釋方法不是生而平等。解釋AI的方法那麼多,哪一個可以信?
過去十年,他做的是同一件事,讓機器學習從基因資料裡挑出線索,再交給生物實驗室去驗。
去年登上Nature Cardiovascular Research的那篇心臟病論文,88頁,就是這樣做出來的。
他叫賓宇,伯克萊的統計學家,美國國家科學院院士。這場的股價只有兩步。
第一步,他主張解釋AI的方法要分級,分級的尺叫Trust,一共五層。
第二步,他拿這把尺去量三個方法
三個都出自他自己的實驗室
在55個學校中
所以開放智能實際上在教育上增長
有些規則
但我認為
如果您問我
可能會有更多的影響
證據也顯示
知識的維護是有問題的
沒有規則
有兩個醫療試驗
一是在土耳其的高中研究室
這是一個比較小的研究室
大型學校研究
這是一個小型學校
我認為在學校層面
發現類似的結果
就是有兩個群體
一個群體使用AI
另一個群體不使用
然後在某些日子後
通常是45%或60%
然後那群體使用AI
有10%的代價
例如
然後我們已經有
AI的禁止在學校中
所以事情正在發生
然後
加利福尼亞在去年
發生了第一次AI安全法
前兩年沒有通過
第二個比較弱的
是關於透明性
而在法律界
人們也有挑戰
而法律的挑戰的價值
非常高
你只需要做
第二個其實涉及
法院的調查
所以非常昂貴
我們無法把所有的案件
都通過這一輪進行調查
總結一下
我對這份工作
有兩位法律同事
丶業務學院的博士 丶業務學院的博士
他們的書名是《互動的能力》
是AI管理基礎的書
我們同意了
這些能力非常發展
在解決大量問題和騙子的方面
他們將從研究室移到計劃中
以使AI成為社會技術系統
這種改變實際上要求社會目標
影響人類和社區
任何試驗或系統研究都很貴
很耗時間
無法在時間中解決所有問題
因此,我認為這種選擇方式
成為社會選擇的基礎
那麼他們如何定義選擇方式
他們把它定義為AI系統必須讓使用者或影響者
理解、理解和複雜 both the system outputs and the underlying assumptions
所以讓使用者的能力成為這個發展的一部分
因為這是社會技術
而具體的說明是他們想要透明度
所以我們必須讓這個系統對使用者來說是理解的
使它們進行諮詢
並正確定模特的內容邏輯
並廣泛的表現
我認為這是一個非常安全的目標
這是我們能夠努力的目標
而且我們需要綜合製作
這個系統支持綜合製作
人類連續執行
和設計的環境
對於教授來說
他們應該有機會
與開放智能設計的系統
與他們的學校合作
我認為學校可以有自己的
關閉系統
不需要使用最先進的
比如環境模組
因為它們有特定的目的
所以你可以在那一層上有開門模組
而且它們有更多的控制
更多的安全吹哨
所以選擇能力
提供了嚴格的科學承諾
以確認這個系統
正在產生在產生
產生在AI中的
產生在產生在AI中的
的批判方法
所以批判方法是
有意義的測試和
AI系統的復興
需要批判方法
讓人體的內部工作
被人體觀察
所謂的危險
是批判方法
比起黑箱
是更危險的
所以批判方法
不是最好
而是更好
而在主要的計劃中,我所提出的工作是在做的,
所以評論、批評都很歡迎,
以以語格的方式去評論評論方法,
以證明可接受的證據。
所以評論方法並沒有一個一個的成分。
有不同的證據,人們可以使用,人們不可以使用。
有些更有信心,有些更有用。
我已經說過,我們需要有主要的計劃,
和構成的系統去評論,以適合可接受的挑戰。
這是我們在2019年出版的執行文章
我們有不同的人在我的群組工作
在訓練機構、訓練訓練、專業訓練
專業訓練、專業訓練
我們放在一起
我們說我們到底是什麼意思
這是2019年
我們推出的主要概念是
我們需要定義人類的觀點或關係
執行文章必須定義
執行文章的執行率
最多的文章中的解釋能力是預測規律的
尤其是在人口觀眾上
我們稱為PDR
就是一個腦子
同時,我們也組織了一個
《組織數據》
文章出版一年後
它們真的詳細地
舉行訓練和數據學習的理論
並且有著傳統的
從參數到參數的準備性到穩定性
包括測試和混合
好的人物判斷
因為PCS實際上是關於工作
通過數據科學或AI
作為系統科學
而數據是一個很重要的部分
因為
人物判斷的價值
你無法定義它沒有詳細
對吧
我一直說我可以把手機放下
我放太多
兩組縮寫
後面會一直出現
先停下來看
PDR在這張圖上是兩個箭頭加一個迴圈
從資料到模型的箭頭叫Predictive Accuracy
問的是模型有沒有學對
從模型到事後分析的箭頭叫Descriptive Accuracy
問的是解釋有沒有照實講出模型學到的東西
迴圈上的R是Relevancy
解釋要對看的人有用
底下那行字說P跟D怎麼取捨
常常由他決定
PCS是下一頁的三個原則
Predictability
結論要過得了現實的檢查
Computability要算得動
Stability
做法在合理的範圍內變動
結論不能跟著變
接下來將近三分鐘
他講的是PCS想當各領域的共同語言
還有哪些單位已經採用
我們跳過
現在是基於基礎模式,我希望變得更大,
第二個,R是Rigors Scalable Epistemic Grounding。
因此,計劃必須要複雜。
如果您真的想檢查或理解AI系統,
so scalability is there.
那麼複雜性就在這裡。
讓專家進行嚴格的系統檢查。
So P for reality check.
這種認識和結果必須有穩定性
不同的人在這個領域
應該沒有兩種不同的認識
關於結果
那你會有問題
你會有太多的聲音在聯繫中
所以這就是幼兒園
我們也想看到
預測和測試
我們稱之為 scope transferability
如果你看到
專業學習
從20-30年前開始
你從來沒有試圖證明你的計劃
有三個標準計劃
至少有十幾百個
之類的
但是如果你看到
進步能力的計劃
人們有那麼少計劃
通常只有三個
或是類似這樣的
你試圖看到計劃是如何
所以非常限制
所以標準計劃
並不符合
公共學習的學習
所以我們必須嘗試
有更多公共計劃
還有私人的合作
人們可以獲得證據
我是個總統
計算機是我們試圖研發很多不同領域的東西
所以對於我來說,這是非常重要的
這種總的解釋計劃不僅僅是用於一個特定的數據
而是用於一整個廣泛的計算機上的問題
但是,一切都不一樣
所以你也應該指出限制
有時候,有些東西不一樣
我教我的課程中,第一個理論就是計算機的數據
一切都不一樣
因此,您必須理解如何,為什麼和當時,這也很重要,
指出限制。
所有這些數據能夠給您一些理解,
但有時候事情不合適。
最後,我認為這就是我們能夠在科學調查中做到的,
就是外部承諾。
這種承諾幫助設計設施,
不僅是您的模擬與您所持有的數據承諾,
我們也會進行網絡測試。
所以這些都是我們的
using each random forest
so which that's what I want to describe
五層由下往上再走一次
最底層解釋要對得上任務跟看的人
也就是剛才的PDR
第二層方法要跑得動大模型
輸出要整理成專家可以逐條審查的形式
第三層不同的人讀同一份解釋
讀到的意思要一樣
第四層換一批相關的資料方法還要有效
最上層照著解釋去設計新的實驗
做出來要對
五層名稱的第一個字母
由下往上排
拼出來就是trust
它沒有名講的一點是成本
底下兩層在電腦前就能驗
最上層要進實驗室
在生物科學上有五六個優秀的獎勵
是根據約翰·卓斯夫拉的研究所獲得的
不要過度估計
約翰·卓斯夫拉共有約60%的基因
所以並不太區別
而約翰·卓斯夫拉的工作有幾十多年
所有的互動都是假的
當我們建立身體的時候
這是約翰·卓斯夫拉的肝臟
人們明白
他們的幾乎所有的基因都合作
來計劃身體計劃
所以我們知道我們不需要,我們不可以只留在二維研究室,我們需要進入高級研究室。
接下來的細節系統,我們實際上是人類,對吧?
GWAS做了很多進步,為一個重要的基因,
但是現在的框架實際上是多維研究室的基因,
這些多維研究室合作來引起的疾病。
例如患上髒細胞疾病,肺炎症,
而我們正在研究這種心臟疾病叫HCM
Hapotrophic Cardiomyopathy
這種疾病在美國發生在500人之中
我們與Stanford Ashley Group合作
我們已經證明了
在早期文章中
有一個基因
我們使用英國BioBank的數據
這種疾病的狀況是
如果你有這種狀況
左脊肌瘤會變大
所以你很難吸引
而且有很嚴重的影響
包括死亡
所以通過E2 random forest framework
我們已經在追求可靠性
所以可靠性
我喜歡評論的哲學家Nancy Cartwright
她說可靠性是一個有足夠的證據來作出行動
所以這就關於證據
我做的行動是做測試
你可能會做醫療測試
你可能會做另一個測試
你可能會做另一個數據收集
所以這是一個評論
而這實際上是試圖在計算機上
機器學習用於選擇選擇數據的數據
也就是選擇數據
並且使它們能夠互動
我們建立了這種生物知識
叫做法蘭斯·弗萊克模式
我們已經顯示過
基因能夠互動
在比較高的程度上
比較高的程度上
而傳統的方式
在100年前的施希爾研究中
有主要的效果
還有第二個程度的聯繫
非常數學化
這實際上顯示了
聯繫的互動
在某些過程中
是正確的
所以人們發現
記得計算器是一種互動的形式
因為你需要這些生物細胞的分離
在細胞上互動
在細胞上有很多聲音
所以它們沒有很明確
所以你需要分離
每個基因都被翻譯成
許多細胞細胞
然後它們必須一起合作
所以這個叫做法蘭茨代表模式
而這個法蘭茨代表模式
是由這種數學形式捕捉的
它是機械性的
它是決定數據
你說分離
例如 gene expression 或 transcription factor 或 protein
在某些程度下,它們會互相互動
在某些程度下,它們不會互動
你能夠找到它們互動的程度
透過你放置的 Boolean 功能
在 machine learning 中,有很長一段決定的歷史
利歐·布萊曼將事情編入了 random forest
每個部門都知道 random forest
所以我不會說更多
有一個步驟
你有很多很多的功能
你取一個組合,例如Mtri的數量,
然後你組合,
在每個組合中,
你不要尋找所有可能的組合,
你做一個組合,
通過組合檢測。
問題是,
人們之前已經想過
用這棵樹來找互動,
所以人們說,
我會翻譯,
如果兩個組合
跌在同一棵樹上,
它們可能會互動。
這也是我們做的。
然而,沒有什麼穩定的。
你把它們撿起來,但沒有什麼是穩定的
所以人們知道的
因此,隱秘的穩定是
額外的解決方法
還有額外的預測
所以它們已經有額外的預測
但是它們沒有額外的預測
因為它們失敗了
隱秘的理論
誰是觀眾?
是生物學家
他們試試試試
試試試試試試試試試試試試試
試試試試試試試試
也是PCS標準的開始
我們取決於預測 random forest
並增加穩定性
我們增加的方式是
我們做第一輪的random forest
第二輪 記住
每個分別
你都要進行純正的測試
在原始的random forest
我們做的
這個random forest
也有重要的數據
所以我們要上測
重要的數據
然後下測
不重要的數據
所以我們做了
轉角測試
還有其他步驟
也不重要
還有後期的
標準標準
以標準穩定性
我們有穩定度數
這就是肥皂增長預測的問題
我不會給你們詳細解釋
每個組合是一個項目
我們有測量器
我們想知道這個項目是否是增強者
在科學上,它就像是自動的推廣器
因此,在基因層面上的翻譯中
事情必須有幫助
這就是增強者的一項目
但是通過3D結構
所以它不必在旁邊
這就是增強者的一項目
你可以看到這三個改變
基本上,這是測試系統
你不會失去任何的準確性
這裡是均衡數據
我們剛剛切換了0.5
是合理的
而這裡有
紅色的是兩個
gene transcription的名稱
而青色的
是三維互動的
所以我們只用了
均衡數據的0.5
為均衡數據
我們有
這個數據是
與這些數據聯合研發的
還有很多的模擬
我會告訴你
從一個特別的
和科學模式的模式
還有一個完全的問題
就是我們在分解中
沒有觸碰任何變化
所以我們至少有兩個真實的問題
一個是我們完全沒有觸碰任何變化
我們發現20個互動的雙雙雙
在文章中
人們已經做過
laser ablation experiments
and 80% were real interactions
so this is
we didn't do the experiment
but it was validated by the literature
and the three-way interaction
that's the frontier of biology
to see whether they can do experiment
to validate that
so become a recommendation
接下來三分鐘是理論
我們跳過止流結論跟彈書
他們把過門檻採取作用
這件事寫成一個數學模型
證明了簡化版的演算法
找得回真正的交互作用
彈書是他自己講的
證明假設每個特徵
互相獨立
各組交互作用
彼此不重疊
而這兩條
在他們手上的問題裡
都不成立
可以有這樣的區域數據
大多數人都共享同樣的
像DNA區域
在某個區域中
這是大多數人的區域數據
這是區域數據
因為大多數人都健康
因此當你區域數據
可能會是疾病的原因
所以這些區域數據叫做
一個細胞細胞
細胞細胞
我們需要改變問題的
均衡
標題不合適
我們需要使用深入學習
去解決重量
和正常化
我們需要解決很多細胞
但是我認為
這些會更有用於其他
細胞類型
我們還使用了GWAS
我們需要進行預測
因為細胞細胞
我們RF
只能使用千億的輸入
所以這裡有一個非常高層次的問題
我們所做的評論
是一個非常低聲音聲音問題
我認為這個問題的數據、數據科學或人工智能
不夠給出確定的結論
我們必須與WETLAB的測試聯合
我們必須重新解決
因為與標準之下
我們無法輸入50%的隨機計劃
所以沒有聲音
你不能做任何事情
如果不能輸入隨機計劃
所以我做了很多事情
我們做了推薦
我們做了分析計劃
我們做了多次預測
我們幾乎沒有達到50%
我們得到了55%
但是我們選擇了不同的方法
我們選擇了用E2RN4
因為有生物證據
銘計計劃也給了55%
但是因為我們想要知識
我們不使用銘計計劃
我們也做了 gene silencing experiment
我們做了幾十多次
我們認為這不是 protein-protein 互動
而是直接的規則
這就是測試
這是另一個不同的故事
因為我們與他們合作
我們重新設計了測試
最後我們找到兩個互動
這篇文章花了很長時間
與博士合作
有88頁
和補充
而在去年在NHK研發研究中
發表了一些評論
第一個評論是38頁
所以實際上是很大的工作
尤其是我們在推動這些
新的數據方法
使用它進行聯絡研發
每個人都在做聯絡模組
所以很耐試
我們做了一個聯絡模組的方式
顯示它沒有
正確的邏輯
所以總結一下
我們有一個有意義的
有意義的生物理論
有意義的解釋
這一頁是他替IRF打的成績
右邊五段說明
字是黑的
就算通過
整頁只有一個詞是橘色
第二層開頭的Scalable
原因在心臟病那一題出現過
1500萬個基因位點
隨機森林吃不下
得先用別的方法篩到幾千個
同一把尺
接下來亮的是深度學習的解釋方法
先亮它實驗室的CDT
CD是Contextual Decomposition
把輸入裡你關心的那幾個字
跟其餘的分開
一層一層往前算
算出那幾個字對輸出貢獻多少
CDT是Transformer的版本
用來自動找電路
也就是模型裡合力完成一件事的
那一小組零件
方法的細節我們跳過
直接聽結果
這個是一個非常簡單的NLP問題
你拿一個文件
例如帕薩勒肺炎
你試圖探索這些組織數據
例如肺炎數據
例如李森的肺炎數據
那裡我們有很多經驗
所以我們可以看到
我們所找到的圖片
確實探索出了更重要的
帕薩勒肺數據
我們有不同的深入學習的版本
根據早期工作的數據輸入
有些比較聯繫的項目
但是我們看到了更大的區別
這是專業與醫學聯盟的參與
但是這不像是做測試
所以這不是同一層標準
但是比較好用標準數據
所以在這裡
我認為我們確定了
預測能力和描述能力
因為醫生能夠理解
而且我們有調整性
但是結果就像
我不知道
如果研究員真的知道
如何解決線路
對吧
除了兩個基因之外
生物科學家都知道
他們自己都明白
所以這是一個不同的層次互動的概念
所以這是一個不同的層次
你給醫生一個鏈接
我不知道
你必須去辨認
回到那個疲倦區域
所以這是一個不同的層次
所以這是為什麼我放了橙色的
不是很
黑色的意思是過去
橙色的意思是
然後我們不知道
所有人都是一樣的
我們談了兩個醫生
關於這些鏈接
那有沒有其他醫生
我們不知道
我認為醫生
還不知道如何辨認鏈接
也許我們會訓練他們
但是現在的情況不太好
而在計算方式上
我們有同樣的問題
和其他計算方式的計算方式
我們有幾個醫療區域的數據
還有這些醫療區域的數據
這些數據是限制的
並不是很多很多的醫療區域的數據
我們絕對沒有這些外部的證據
除了有些醫生在評論中
所以我認為
這不是另一部分的好處
Of course, I modeled the framework
同一座金字塔,顏色變了
最底層還是黑字
第二層只剩scalable是黑的
後半句變成橘色
第三層整段也是
第四層跟最上層是紅字
紅色他沒有解釋
對照他剛才的話就是沒過
資料只有幾個benchmark
加一份病理報告
外部驗證沒有做
第二個方法叫specs
走的是另一條路
不看模型內部
只把輸入的字遮掉一部分
再問模型
問很多次
再用編碼理論的工具
反推哪幾個字是一起起作用的
後續的Proxy Specs
把要問的次數壓到十分之一
細節一樣跳過
看他打的成績
最後兩分鐘
他講的是一個還在進行的計劃
叫Green Shielding
為每天的使用者提供的守護
我們有三個欄目
我們想要有一個代表
為其他使用者做的事情
我們想要做一個系列的測試
實際上是用很多的後途
以為能夠與醫生聯繫
知道他們的相關的標準
我們想要做一個像這樣的規則
我們有同樣的疾病
有同樣的系統
您可能會問這些問題
比我更不一樣
而根據您的發問
答案可能比其他人更有用
I mean this is psycho-fancy behavior
that make you happy
but sometimes can be detrimental
有時候我們只是想
and then they might agree
所以名字肯定是
right teaming called green shielding
we try to do benign real world input
now that's very prompt
we want routine user variations
we want validation driven
we want mitigation evaluation
so green shielding enable contestability
so I will just go
我們有一個實際的試驗
我總是把某些東西放在某些實際的東西上
然後我們首先證明了引起的因素
我們證明了,例如,模擬
情緒真的改變了一些東西
然後我們設計了一個平衡器
所以我們取得情緒的進入
我們取消了情緒
然後我們可以看到
其實它真的改變了反應
問題是現在是否更好
我們降低了範圍
首先,
醫生拒絕幫助標明,
因為他說,
你不給我足夠的資訊,
我現在不去判斷醫生的診斷,
但醫生非常高興給予很多種診斷,
它可以讓人很擔心,
所以我們現在進行診斷,
並且我們也改變了診斷,
診斷實際上是一個問題,
是不符合診斷的資訊,
他們無法診斷,
所以我們改變了什麼叫管理思維,
問不同的問題是關鍵的,
所以醫生的評價要有很多的互動。
總結來說,我認為這是新的意義執行方案,
我們將將我們之前的工作建立,
我們想要區別不同的執行方案,
使用者可以知道,
就像是一個領導,
我們會測試這三個方案,
我提到的是綠線保護。
未來的工作,
我們看到很多人在這裡做的環境執行工作,
我認為他們可以成為我們的真實的基礎,
這就是錯誤的真相
我們要看我們的計劃是否正確
我們要找到正確的計劃
另一個原因是
我們想讓CDT有更多的證據
或者我們要做得更好
改善結果
越來越實際
實際的解決模式
越來越成為正確計劃
我希望我們能在中間聯繫
我們可以幫助兩者
因為最終
正確計劃將被用於
真正的AI系統
但我認為這個方法可以增加更多實際性的實際性
例如我的批評分析模式是一個這樣的模式
從深入學習而來的
整場收成兩句
第一 解釋方法要分級
錯的解釋會給人假的安全感
所以要看它背後有多少證據
最硬的一種是照著解釋去做實驗
第二 拿Trust這把尺量
有實驗撐腰的IRF幾乎全過
它自己的兩個深度學習方法只站穩了最底層
還沒做到的
他也講了Trust的論文還沒投出去
此又是照IRF的經驗定的
拿去量別的領域準不準
還要更多案例
下一場是史丹佛的Christopher Potts
要講一個聽起來不太可能的現象
先讓一個模型愛貓
再叫它只寫數字
拿這些數字去訓練另一個模型
數字裡一個貓字都沒有
第二個模型卻也愛上了貓
這個現象叫Subliminal Learning
這一場要示範的是
怎麼在訓練之前
就從資料裡把它抓出來
原影片連結在說明欄
整場46分鐘
有興趣可以去聽更多